okay today I'm going to talk about how
to succeed with a startup obviously more
than can be said here in 20 minutes but
I will do the best I can the most
important thing the number one lesson we
try to teach startups is that the degree
to which you're successful approximates
the degree to which you build a product
that is so good people spontaneously
tell their friends about it startups
always ask us for the secret to success
they always want to believe it's
something other than this because this
is really hard to do but this is it if
you can build a product that is so good
people spontaneously tell their friends
about it you have done 80% of the work
that you need to be a really successful
startup if you think about the most
successful companies you know Google
Facebook whatever you probably found out
about them because a friend of yours
said you got to try this it's great so
this is the bar something that people
love so much they tell their friends
about it
one important indicator for a product
like that is a product it's simple to
explain and easy to understand if you
can't explain in a few words what you do
and if people don't if at least some
people don't say oh that's pretty
interesting
that's usually a mistake it's usually a
sign of unclear thinking or a need that
is not big enough
another thing that startups need to look
for is a market that is either started
to undergo or is soon going to under
grow exponential growth I think this is
actually related to one of the biggest
mistakes investors make when evaluating
startups investors always say well
what's your growth rate we care about
the growth rate investors will forgive
smallish revenue today if it's growing
quickly for some reason people don't
think about markets this way but if you
think about the most important startups
they are the ones that I start in small
markets that are growing very very
quickly 11 years ago the market for
iPhone apps is zero dollars it's not
huge and I think if you only think about
the TAM today you'll make a big mistake
what you really want to do is identify a
market that's going to grow every year
and be able to ride that up elevator a
really important thing to figure
figuring this out is learning how to
differentiate between real trends and
fake trends a real trend is something
that's actually going to happen in the
fake trend is not or at least not yet
and before
you make a big bet on a new platform you
want to make sure it's real now there's
an easy trick for this which I'll share
now real trends are ones where a new
technology platform comes along and the
early adopters use it obsessively and
tell the friends how much they love it
a fake trend is one where people may buy
the product but don't use it or at least
not enough so an example of a real trend
I already mentioned the iPhone I'll
mention that again when the iPhone first
came out many people were dismissive
because they only sold a million or two
million that year and they said well
this just doesn't matter but for the
people that had an iPhone they used it
for hours every day it became central to
their lives they loved it they told
their friends you've got to get one and
I think it was obvious then do people
pay an attention that something had
fundamentally shifted and we had a new a
new computing platform that was gonna
spawn huge businesses and it was a good
time to bet on mobile apps a fake trend
or at least a fake trend as of august
2018 I would say as VR I do believe VR
will be big someday but today most
people that I know that own a VR headset
use it never or very rarely and so
although a lot of people talk about it
and maybe even a lot of people buy them
there's not the intense usage per user
among the early adopters that I think
you want to see before you make a big
bet another thing that startups need at
least one evangelical founder usually
the CEO someone at the startup has got
to be the person that is going to
recruit sell the product talk to the
press
raise money and this requires someone
who can infect with enthusiasm the whole
world about what the company is trying
to do and someone who becomes the chief
evangelist for the company it's very
hard to succeed wildly without that it's
very hard to build a team at all without
being able to do that one thing that
helps for this is having an ambitious
vision you never want to be grandiose
that turns people off but you want to
let yourself grow more ambitious over
time and as long as you do that
organically people will respond
ambitious visions are exciting they're
fun to work on in fact I think in 2018
at least in Silicon Valley it's easier
to start a hard
startup than it is to start an easy
startup now this sounds paradoxical but
ambitious projects are interesting you
know in the current environment it may
be relatively easy to raise capital but
it's really hard to do everything else
there are so many startups it's so easy
to start one they all sound so promising
that that bringing together enough
talent in one organization is really
hard to do and if you're working on a
problem that you know maybe modestly
successful it's it's kind of easy to get
the first two people to join you can
give them a lot of equity but then it
gets really hard why is employee xx
gonna join why is this why does this
matter to the world why should someone
work on your startup versus any of the
other things they could do and picking
something that matters if you're
successful is a great way to do that and
so I think it's really important to
think about when you're starting a
company how is this going to evolve into
a vision that a lot of people want to
help with but a lot of people want to be
associated with because I think getting
talent and getting mindshare it is
really hard in the current environment
and people are interested in startups
that matter another thing that we've
noticed among our best Saunders again
and again and again is that they are
have a confident and definite view of
the future they may be wrong and so we
say it's good to be confident and
flexible but this idea that you are
confident in definite this is what I
think is going to happen or this is what
is going to happen and being relatively
sure of that having courage of your
convictions being a clear leader saying
we're gonna do this and that's why even
in the face of a lot of doubt that seems
to really correlate with success and
this comes back to having an ambitious
vision but the entire startup ecosystem
is best set up to support companies that
have a low chance of success but are
huge if they work and I think going for
something that is huge if it works will
attract the best people
not going to talk too much about the
team there are a lot of obvious things I
could say that have been said many times
by many people about you know you need
smart people who want to work really
hard and who communicate well these are
all really true but I'd like to mention
a few non-obvious things that we've
noticed that we don't hear people say as
much about the team you need to assemble
the note Khosla says that the team you
build is the company you build and I
really think that's true I've still met
only a handful of founders I think that
spend enough time on recruiting like
Mark Zuckerberg is famously one of them
but building a great team I think other
than picking the right market and
building a great product is the most
important thing you do all founders go
through a transition all successful
founders where you switch from building
a product to building a company and
building a company really is about the
team so you need to mist the whole world
will be telling you why you're gonna
fail as a start-up if you don't have
that internal fire of belief if you
don't have people who say you know what
we are gonna do this and it doesn't
matter what the haters say we're gonna
figure this out and there is you know
this problem it must be solvable if you
don't have the spirit of optimism on the
team it's very hard to succeed when the
world continues to punch you in the face
you need at least some idea generators
there are a handful of people in any
company that has gone on to be really
successful that I that I've been able to
work with who are just really good at
coming up with lots of ideas you don't
too many these people because that's
more ideas than a company can follow
through on but having some people within
a company that are just constantly
throwing out new ideas most of which
will be bad it turns out to be super
important to have on the team this
spirit of we'll figure it out is my
favorite thing to hear among early
startup team members a lot of things go
wrong the situations that startups win
in tend to be incredibly dynamic and so
this idea that even if I'm not qualified
on paper even if I haven't solved this
problem before even if this problem
feels like it's gonna kill the company
which many problems will feel that way
this spirit among the team of you know
what we've got the
people we need we're gonna figure this
out we're gonna get this done that's
super important another thing that I
love to hear from early team members is
I've got it so you know you hear in big
companies a lot of people say that's not
my department someone else is gonna do
that yeah or you know who this is really
bad this is gonna hurt us and you want
people who just step up and say I'll do
it I've got it don't worry about it you
want people to have a bias towards
action startups especially in their
early days often win by moving very
quickly you never get as much data as
you'd like you never have as much time
to deliberate as you'd like and you want
people who will are willing to act with
much less data than they'd like to have
with much less certainty and then if
they act then it doesn't work they adapt
really quickly and try something else we
talk also about the blessing of
inexperience we have seen many of our
startups do incredible things because no
one told them it was hard no one told
them they can't do it um there's a great
quote from Steve Wozniak about how all
the best things he ever did came from
having no experience whatsoever and
having no money and you know that
obviously is not always true but there
is a magic thing that happens with
startups especially in their early days
before they've learned they're not
supposed to be able to do certain things
and so I think as a start-up again
doesn't work to have everybody being
experienced but you can take more bets
than you normally would on inexperienced
but super high potential people that's
the end of a topic on on team one of the
most important jobs you have as a
founder is to never lose momentum and
this is a little bit depressing because
it means for the first few years you
never get to take your foot off of the
gas you never get to really rest we try
to be honest about this that startups
are not the best choice for work-life
balance at all but especially in the
early days startups survive on their own
momentum if you have momentum people
keep delivering results beyond what they
think they're capable of if you lose
momentum it's very difficult to get it
back and so continuing to make sure that
the startup has a cadence that the
startup keeps winning on a relatively
predictively short and predictable and
this is really important and it's up to
the founders to make sure that that you
don't lose ahold of this
another thing that we think startups
need is a competitive advantage over
time now this is something that sounds
so obvious I hesitated to even put it in
this is well discussed but we're seeing
more and more startups apply to YC and
when we ask them so what is the long
term monopoly effect here what is the
long term competitive advantage what is
you know where is the network effect in
this business they look at us like it's
the first time we've ever they've ever
heard this question all of the really
great businesses I know have an answer
to this question and in fact the better
they are the more they pretend not to
but this is something that you you want
to have a plan for another thing you
want to have a plan for is at least a
sensible business model you don't have
to have it all figured out at the
beginning but when we ask founders so
how are you ever going to make money and
they look at us like it's the first time
they've ever been asked that question
which happens more often than you would
think recently that's a bad sign too
again this one is so common that I
hesitate to put it in here
but when we ask a start-up how they're
gonna grow how they're gonna get users
and they look at us like it's the first
time they've ever heard that question
bad sign so some sensible idea to try
here first
Paul Buchheit once spent a bunch of time
looking one of the YC partners spent a
bunch of time looking at the traits of
our best founders and tried to distill
down what they were and he came up with
a frugality focus obsession and love
I actually I think that is really good I
don't know how much to add but I think
these are things that you should be able
to say about what you're doing and you
as a founder and finally I want to talk
about why startups get to be big
companies we've there are lots of
reasons I'm going to talk about a few
common ones here I think these trends
are valuable enough that as you evaluate
startup ideas you might do it's worth
thinking about if you fit into these
because it's really hard for startups to
beat big companies most of the time and
here are some areas where we see it
happening repeatedly
so I think one difference is if you are
a product manager at a big company and
you want to do something that sounds
sounds like a bad idea but is a good
idea you have to get everybody from your
boss sometimes all the way up to the CEO
to say yes so one no can kill you if
you're a start-up you can go to I see
demo day any number of the thousands of
investors can say yes and you get to
have a crack at it so it's a very
different mindset and for those ideas
that sound bad but are good because of
this phenomenon this one no versus one
yes startups can win in fact startups
usually do beat big companies in that
category of ideas so look look for ideas
that sound bad but are good and where
you are much more likely to get one yes
then someone in a big company is to get
all yeses another area where startups
usually be big companies aren't very
fast changing markets startups great
speed great advantage is an agility and
speed the more a market is changing the
higher the number of decisions you get
to make and the higher number of tweaks
to your product and your strategy you
get to make and you want to optimize the
number of those decisions that someone
has to make to compete with you because
a big company will make them on average
worse than certainly much slower than
you do so the speed of market evolution
gives you a lot more chances to compound
your advantage over a big company and
then finally startups usually win on big
platform shifts many people have
observed that startups companies
clusters those clusters usually come
after a big platform shift we'll stick
with the iPhone example here after
mobile apps became a thing many new
companies got started that are now quite
valuable and one of the reasons here is
you know most large companies work on
sort of an annual cadence at least and
when there's a huge platform shift they
are not good at making a big enough
strategic pivot the Battleship just
turns too slowly whereas a start-up can
say wow woke up this morning the world
is fundamentally different than it was
six months ago we're gonna go all in on
this new direction and so that's a way
that startups usually win or that that's
an area where startups usually win there
there are many others but thinking about
these three I think is is directionally
a good thing to do alright that's all
I've got for today Jeff thank you very
much for having me and for the class
you